but yes the take your power back anthem
itself is in order for us to read in
order for us to like look at what world
we want to live in whatever whatever
that world looks like we have to as as
so many of our great gurus and teachers
have taught us --is we have to we have
to mend and heal and allow our inner
heaven to be the focus so that we can
dump out all this other crap and allow
allow that alignment to happen so you
know someone's like yeah I'm good you
know and you can say that with complete
conviction that in it and then also in
that truth we were like I'm not good no
yeah so there's there's a lot of content
in there there's a lot of there's
there's songs directed at certain things
I mean there's the song twisted and part
problem these are two of my favorite
songs in the album that are singles that
have already come out but they're very
much about kind of what we're saying in
this self love this like shocking moment
of going like god I thought I was doing
this the right way I thought I was
taking care of myself I thought it was
being honest and being real and you know
being transparent and like and
communicating when in fact I was
manipulating myself this whole time
because I had this backdoor plan even
though I didn't even realize it and and
I had all these mad control issues
around everything and and so that was
what this was about it was like man I
haven't been loving myself I haven't
been taking the time to take care of
myself and I haven't been giving myself
the most attention but I need to feel
healthy and whole you know whether
that's committing to a practice of some
kind or committing to you know
cutting something out of my life you
know it's those kinds of things that
that I needed to take a big look at and
also saying like it's okay to raise your
hand and ask for help yeah it's really
hard it's really hard especially for
guys were so prideful we're just like
you know it's not really in our training
to to get help or to be vulnerable
[Music]